douze ans après la précédente édition
voici le tout nouveau guide alimentaire
canadien qu'est ce que vous en pensez de
ce nouveau libre et je suis très content
achevée très optimiste pour l'avenir
pas étonnant qu'ils aiment le nouveau
guide il se rapproche de celui du brésil
une référence en la matière auxquelles
monsieur moubarak a lui-même collaborer
il ya beaucoup d'éléments donc de ce
guide là qu'ils sont inspirés du guide
brésilienne le fait de parler du
contexte de consommation donc comment
les gens mangent au delà de ce qu'on
mange donc d'avoir un rapport plus
humain face aux aliments un rapport
peut-être plus humain aussi face à
l'environnement à la santé des plantes
des animaux
pour nous c'est pas nouveau c'est pas
révolutionnaire ce guide la
nutritionniste hélène laurendeau nous
conseille sur nos habitudes alimentaires
depuis plus de trente ans quand j'ai vu
ça m'a tout de suite plu parce que ça
ressemble à ce que moi je prêche dans
mes conférences dans d'enda avec ma
famille avec les enfants
dans les versions précédentes on parlait
de portions alors que le nouveau guide
part plutôt de proportion de quoi en
inquiéter certains
il a tout d'un coup on leur dit le
nouveau guide un puis deux morceaux puis
c'est comme ma petite portion mais là on
est complètement déstabilisée pourtant
c'est simple
notre assiette devrait être composé d'un
card aliments protéinés d'un quart de
produits à base de grains entiers et
deux moitiés de fruits et légumes
quand on mange plus de végétaux on a
fait ce qu'on a on a une meilleure santé
cardiovasculaire on n'a pas ce qu'on a
moins de gras saturés
on a plus de fibres donc c'est
rassasiant donc c'est bon pour notre
microbiote intestinal et c'est aussi bon
pour prévenir plusieurs types de cancers
dans le nouveau guide on nous encourage
à éviter les boissons sucrées dont font
partie les jus de fruits certains se
réjouiront de la disparition du verre de
jus d'orange dans un contexte où on
consomme trop de calories aujourd'hui le
jus d'orange devient vraiment un excès
on serait beaucoup mieux de le remplacer
par des vrais fruits un kiwi les
batteries maxime une range entière qu'on
voit peu les savourer mastiquer pour
ralentir la vitesse à laquelle on mange
plutôt que kelly soglo guiglo et puis là
tout à coup c'est comme le tsunami de
sucres libres qui arrive dans l'eau
devient donc la boisson de choix qui on
peut la jazz et on met un morceau de
gags remet dedans un peu de citron une
feuille de menthe une fraise basilique
quant aux produits laitiers ils font
toujours partie du guide mais il se
retrouve dans la catégorie aliments
protéinés
ce qui a créé une polémique pourquoi les
gens ont l'impression qu'une loi de
boire du lait dans l'ensemble aucun
aliment n'est banni
moi le premier je vais continuer à
consommer des produits laitiers belges a
peut-être en consommer moins et donc
réfléchir à leur place dans mon
alimentation est plutôt que de choisir
des fromages moins gras et moins ça
l'est peut-être à manger moins
et dans la section aliments protéinés ce
n'est pas le choix qui manque
en plus des produits laitiers on propose
des viandes rouges maigre des volailles
et du poisson mais santé canada insiste
sur le fait de manger davantage
d'aliments protéines et de sources
végétales
par exemple les légumineuses les noix et
le tofu faut arrêter de voir le gros
thibault avec le petit bouquet de persil
kaki et le légumes la viande on la
choisit on en mange moins et puis on la
savoure
puis on est heureux mais on devient ce
moment là l'accompagnateur de ce trois
quarts d'assiette locke key beaucoup
plus une ode au végétal c'est la nature
c'est qu'est ce qu'on peut demander
mieux le guide est clair il faut
consommer moins de sucre de sel et de
gras souvent très présent dans les
produits transformés
est ce que le consommateur va pouvoir
appliquer ça dans sa vie tous les jours
bientôt bon sur le site de santé canada
il ya des repères et des conseils très
pratiques très intéressant donc il faut
aller lire et regarder ses conseils
entre autres on nous conseille pour
éviter de consommer trop d'aliments
hautement transformés
on nous conseille de n'est pas ne
palliera bien la maison
en fait de ne pas les avoir dans notre
dans notre placard parce que si on a des
biscuits et de la crème glacée sous les
yeux bas ils font plus rapidement sous
le soleil
c'est vrai que dans l'ensemble et mes
recherches l'ont démontré les produits
hautement transformés sont moins chers
que l'ensemble des vrais aliments c'est
possible de se nourrir sainement sans se
ruiner faut tout simplement prendre le
temps de cuisiner nous a lavé le cerveau
depuis des années qu'on manque de tables
qu'on n'est pas capable de cuisiner
bon moi je fais un peu philosophe en
disant on ne possède pas le temps il
faut prendre le temps le temps file
constamment et on prend le temps pour
des choses qu'on valorise donc si on on
comprend réalise l'importance de la
saine alimentation et de la cuisine on
veut y accorder du temps idée de nice et
pas de manger comme ça 100% du temps à
l'école dit toujours quant à 80% dans
ton examen était content si on mange
vraiment de façon exemplaire
la majorité du temps le reste l'autre
tant voir un match du canadien
tu manges gâteries là au centre bell
c'est correct
et puis on veut tous vivre éternellement
il va falloir qu'on range mieux
[Musique]